since going back to actors in so many of
us have been groomed all their lives to
please people and be sort of the
characters that we see people kind of
want us to
intuitively
that people want us to be that way what
advice would you give to an actor
I always have the feeling when I'm
sitting in casting sessions that we are
seeing 200 people the day for the same
role and everyone is trying to do exact
justice to what's on the page because
exactly what you are saying there they
think they have figured out what the
director wants the retroactivity you see
198 people that are doing it the same
way they're doing the ! with the ! is on
the page there doing the pause where it
says paula zahn of it and then that one
person comes in who doesn't care and who
suddenly puts a paw swear I've never
heard it before and who suddenly changes
his rhythm or changes the speed or
whispers align that I've never heard
whispered people doesn't mean that
that's no I had it in my head before but
I'm suddenly waking up from something
like wait a minute so it's suddenly 198
people against that one guy so like a
50-50 chance so that guy so he has a
fifty percent chance of making it into
the next round whereas all these other
198 are sharing their fifty percent
they're just getting lost you know
so if I were an actor I would just take
that risk every single time and think I
understand what the director wants and I
know that everyone else is trying to
give them a let us do some variation
that some spin on that let's go inspire
and doesn't have to be light at all cuz
we're gonna do the second run through
anyway with a completely different
adjustment just to see how much an actor
can adjust to so even if someone comes
in dues exactly what I had in my mind
for the second take I'll completely
change it up and say do it as a
four-year-old just to see if they
actually change because if it doesn't
change that just means that actor got
lucky with the first day and he's not
always going to get lucky and if I can
can't adjust him on set then I'm screwed
so that will be my vice tractors just do
something that will
wake up and remember you and not
necessarily before the scene starts
because there are some people that
bringing props or comic costumes which I
always think it's kind of a desperate
thing I was like whew that doesn't it
doesn't start well and then they can't
have to make up for
yo
if you see an actor on set that's two
too much in our head
stew them in another direction you said
maybe try it as a four-year-old
but what's a way to do it especially if
it's a 10
I think you have to one trick that that
always work was to say we got it that
was brilliant tape that's just the one
for safety or giving the cinematographer
we have my cinematographer Hungaria and
he speaks German so we could always keep
German upset without anyone else
noticing and I could give him a sign
that he would say can we do one for
technical term speak up and suddenly the
actor work relax because they are like
oh we hit it and it's great and we got a
tape now let's just do one you no trust
for for safety and we actually don't
have it yet the active as melon and then
it suddenly works I think it's all about
that stress and that pressure and
network for overacting malavan always
had this trip when someone was fit was
overacting with their voice that she
would say what's your address and people
would tell her their address and then
she would be like that voice because
everything she called the address voice
Kira and it's true that if someone just
saying their address there is no acting
there is no character they're putting on
there just talking in their natural
and someone suddenly people were talking
about town lower or higher lever adjust
to their normal voice so there are
tricks with them and then there are just
games where you just kind of take a
break and do something improve depending
on whether the actor likes that or not
it's it's kind of interesting because
different actors work so differently and
if you match them and work with them you
have have to figure out how each actor
work some people hate improv and that
doesn't relax them at all but it kind of
makes them takes them out of it and the
concentration is gone and other actors
suddenly discover things and we're
seeing that they never knew before so
it's going to take a couple of days I
think until you figure out how everyone
wants to work and then how you make them
work together they're different teams
but it's that's some of the fun part
just all about I was always trying to
make it more about the group and that
what they could give to each other then
to what I could give to the single
actors because they are going to be the
ones that are playing together in the
seat they're gonna relate to each other
in
I if I it doesn't matter how strong the
bond is that I have with the actor once
they go into the scene you know that's
almost a bad thing I need them to bond
with their fellow actors so there are
tricks to make that just have them
you spent time together before the
portal for the my second film I had the
actress that were supposed to be a
family spend a day together in the park
and play games share secrets I've had
these little index cards with tasks that
I had to do tell the other person really
embarrassing secret that know that I
will never know as director and it's
important that I don't you know it's
important that they have the feeling
they have a stronger bond than I have
with and especially if in the movie they
are supposed to have a back story I
think again that's something that you
can either try to act and you are always
running the risk that we look actor or
you can try to create that you know
create memories that it's just one
weekend ago that's fine but still
translate as these people have a
connection they haven't just met that
morning on set another pertaining to
hospital
you